qu'il dénationaliser et comment
l'opposition qui prépare ses projets en
la matière vient de recevoir le rapport
d'un expert invité de soir3 jacques
chaban delmas il va nous parler de ses
projets pour l'après 86 cents cinquante
ans aujourd'hui et les projets jusqu'à
la fin du siècle l'agencé france presse
est l'une des trois grandes agences
mondiales d'information afrique du sud
la grande bretagne adopte du bout des
lèvres des mesures timides contres
pretoria mesdames messieurs bonsoir
s'est dit ce que n'était pas au hit
parade mais sa mort va laisser un grand
vide dans la chanson française jean
roger caussimon vient de mourir d'un
cancer à paris à l'âge de 67 ans il
était d'abord comédien compositeur et
puis sur le tard vers 40 ans il s'était
mis à chanter lui même c'était surtout
un poète dont bien des grands noms
chanter les textes ferrer gréco
catherine sauvage
il avait également écrit cinq pièces de
théâtre dont la dernière a été jouée
tout récemment à paris enfin vous m'avez
plonge
i de pluie ni de chapeau à qui la faute
à qui la cause
s'il n'est plus de fleurs ou d'oiseaux
les roses sont artificielles oiseaux qui
passent dans le week-end et sur les sept
accusés officiel
des pigeons noir seul pour lequel
mon fils est dans la fleur de l'âge et
moi qui mets du temps jadis
je m'en vais pointer au chômage ou
s'inscrire à bientôt mon fils aux jeunes
est ce que retient des larmes devant le
mur de l'avenir car sinon pays vend des
armes
je n'ai pas porte entretenir à cinq mois
des élections législatives le débat sur
les binationaux alisation se précisent
les partis de l'opposition n'ont
toujours pas défini précisément ce qu'il
ferait des industries et des autres
entreprises du secteur public s'il
revenait au pouvoir mais un avocat
d'affaires m loyrette vient de réaliser
pour eux une étude très détaillée
un rapport de 300 pages pour guider
leurs réflexions et selon lui il
faudrait des 86 privatiser 47
entreprises
marie-claire tiers la privatisation sera
maximale
elle touchera les entreprises
nationalisées depuis 1982 cge saint
gobain thompson rhône poulenc pechiney
matra bull d'assaut côté bancaires
paribas suez et celle d'avant 82 sacilor
usinor cdf chimie renault côté bancaire
crédit lyonnais bnp société générale où
les groupes d'assurances uatp agf et
gagnent dans quel délai un an pour les
plus rentables qui passeront les
premières en priorité les banques suez
et paribas 2 à 3 ans pour les autres
mais pas de délai précis pour les
entreprises dans le rouge comme renault
seuls y échapperaient les entreprises
publiques exerçant un monopole d'état
sncf ptt ratp et df gdf et charbonnages
de france
cette vente se ferait par introduction
en bourse
attribution d'actions au personnel et
libéralisme oblige participation
étrangère une opération qui
représenterait une valeur de 130
milliards de francs environ sur cinq ans
et pour éviter toute nouvelle tentative
de nationalisation une réforme
constitutionnelle verrouillerait le
système les interventions en nombreuses
et remarquée de jean marie le pen la
semaine dernière continue de susciter
beaucoup de réactions chez les
journalistes d'abord dont plusieurs ont
été mis en cause nommément par le leader
du front national et puis réaction aussi
dans les partis politiques de
l'opposition
écouter celle de michel noir député rpr
du rhône qui s'exprimait tout à l'heure
à lyon nous avons toujours dit que nous
n'avons pas traiter du problème des
personnalités dirigeants du front
national nous avons à regarder ce qu'ont
voulu exprimer des électeurs qui sont
allés chercher ce ce vote le sort et ce
besoin effectivement d'autorité de
l'état et qu'ensemble de règles du jeu
soient redéfinies en tout cas respecté
et nous allons être attentifs à ceux ci
sur la deuxième partie de votre question
je trouve que c'est vraiment le comble
de l'irresponsabilité et la perte de
sang froid
désigné comme ça après avoir désigné des
gens qu'on voulait tuer par balles
désigner des têtes de journalistes qu'on
veut te faire disparaître je trouve que
c'est là un propos complètement
irresponsable et qui désigne de façon
dramatique l'absence de sérieux et de
100 francs de l'intéressé mais ça c'est
un sentiment que je qui était le mien
depuis longtemps et ça me fait
malheureusement que le conforter
invité de soir3 jacques chaban delmas et
avant que fernand tavarès ne vous
interroge sur l'après 86 j'aimerais
savoir monsieur le premier ministre
comment vous avez réagi vous aux propos
de monsieur le pen la semaine dernière
aux jeux c'est pas de la semaine
dernière en réalité de ce côté là il ya
des résonances qui me déplaisent
souverainement et ce n'est pas de ce
côté là que j'irai chercher des soutiens
quels qu'ils soient et où que ce soit ce
savant delmas hier et avant-hier vous
étiez en gironde
le secrétaire général du rpr monsieur
toubon et est à vos côtés et il ya une
petite phrase qui n'est pas passé
inaperçu il a dit que en cas de victoire
de l'opposition actuelle après 86 eh
bien il faudrait que le nouveau
gouvernement s'inspire de l'esprit de la
nouvelle société je pense que c'était un
type peut-être un petit appel du pied
vous êtes toujours disponible pour après
86 fait moi je suis toujours disponible
quand il veut travailler mais je suis
sans l'avidité je suis pas à la
recherche d'un emploi j'ai en effet la
chance d'avoir beaucoup de travail à
bordeaux en aquitaine est également à
paris pour suivre les affaires de l'état
et je pense que l'opposition aujourd'hui
doit se préparer sérieusement à ce qu'on
appelle l'alternance et que pour y
parvenir elle doit présenter des
propositions des projets assez clair
sans entrer dans les détails alors je
sais que vous n'aimez pas trop qu'on
vous reparle de cohabitation et pourtant
si vous êtes chef du gouvernement il va
bien falloir y penser ce sera peut-être
pas facile pour vous ce ne sera
peut-être pas facile non plus pour le
président actuel si le récent du quercy
foot et je propose que les questions
personnelles soient laissés de côté
lorsque vraiment la question ne se pose
pas et d'abord on n'est pas candidat à
un poste qui dépend de la volonté d'un
seul
or premier ministre c'est la désignation
par un seul homme qui le président de la
république
donc on n'est pas candidat à un poste
désigné par un seul et vous pensez bien
qu ayant l'expérience de matignon j'ai
passé trois ans je n'y retournerai pas
pour y retourner
je n'y retournerais que si j'ai les
mains libres
c'est à dire d'une part vis-à-vis du
président de la république dans
l'application stricte de la constitution
donc le gouvernement détermine et
conduit la politique de la nation et
vis-à-vis de la majorité
well hypothétique n'oublions pas que
tout ça ce sont des hypothèses mais
avant il faudra gagner sur le terrain
s'est jamais gagné à l'avancé comme les
matchs et bien vis-à-vis de la majorité
il est bien certain que j'irai dans le
sens général de cette nouvelle majorité
puisque moi-même je fais campagne
actuellement dans cette opposition
et pour cette opposition mais avec mon
style et mes ambitions pour la france et
les français et les aspirations disons
le qui n'ont pas varié mais en tant que
président du conseil régional
d'aquitaine où vous livrer que même en
fermant à une expérience de cohabitation
georges tron ont toujours le même mot
vous présidez fait région et vous avez à
vos côtés des membres de l'actuelle
majorité
loin des radicaux de gauche alors
comment cette cohabitation
fonctionne-t-elle en région mais elle
fonctionne très bien
elle fonctionne très bien parce que sur
le plan régional
ça c'est différent du plan national sur
j'ai posé en principe que les problèmes
à résoudre était de telle nature que la
politique 99 fois sur 100 la politique
partisane n'avait rien à y voir
alors en effet avec les radicaux de
gauche et nous formons un ensemble et
jusqu'à présent nous n'avons pas trouvé
un seul sujet de désaccord
bien sûr il faut examiner les choses
très sérieusement et on trouve les
solutions d'accord pour agir et on agit
revenons au plan national tout à l'heure
vous entendu parler d'une liste de
dénationalisation possible quelle est
votre politique à ce sujet votre point
de vue d'une manière générale sauf pour
des monopoles d'état pour tout ce qui
est concurrentiel pour ma part j'opte
pour l'entreprise privée de préférence
l'entreprise publique pas par idéologie
mais pour des raisons d'efficience
d'efficacité donc des nationalisations
oui mais des nationalisations dans la
mesure du possible et ce n'est que quand
on arrivera là sur le terrain qu'on sera
ce qu'il est possible de faire alors des
projets du sang de ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui publiés ont leur intérêt et
l'opposition aura à prendre les elle
mène des positions et puis on verra le
moment venu si le moment vient ce qui
est possible ou alors nous parlions de
nouvelles sociétés
si vous étiez à nouveau appelés aux
affaires est ce que vous reprendriez à
vos côtés par exemple un homme comme
jacques delors
je vous ai dit que les questions
personnelles devait être complètement
écartée
ce qui est vrai c'est qu'à une époque où
nous avons les nouveaux pauvres
nous avons de la misère qui revient une
nouvelle société plus juste et plus
humaine s'imposera davantage encore
qu'il ya 15 ans car il faudra éviter une
société dans laquelle il y aurait d'une
part des gens qui travaillent qui vont
de l'avant
et puis les miséreux par conséquent la
nouvelle société s'imposera plus que
jamais je vous remercie
un grand patron d'industrie est mort la
nuit dernière jean riboud président
jusqu'au mois dernier du groupe
schlumbergera riboud été vaincu par un
cancer à l'âge de 65 ans c'était pas un
des rares français à avoir présidé une
multinationale américaine l'une des
sociétés les mieux gérées du monde de
l'aveu même des économistes selon mme
berger le numéro un de la recherche
pétrolière
ce grand patron était aussi un homme de
gauche ami personnel de très longue date
de françois mitterrand dont on a dit
souvent qu'il avait conseillé à man
occasion jean ribes ou était enfin un
homme de culture il avait en particulier
beaucoup aidé et henri langlois a sauvé
la cinémathèque française
l' agence france-presse fête ces
jours-ci ses 150 ans peut-être ne
soupçonnez vous pas ce qui se cache sous
ce sigle
afp il faut que vous sachiez que pour
tous les journaux les radios et les
télévisions c'est un instrument de
travail quotidien est indispensable
c'est l'une de nos sources
d'informations essentielles
la fp est présente dans le monde entier
diffusent chaque jour un million de mots
en six langues et elle n'a que deux
concurrents un américain assez sa tête
presse est une agence anglaise greutert
hubert coudurier
il aurait fallu en attente de choses à
répétition à votre demande de pierre
faber
oui bonjour pendant quelques minutes
problème de matériel et la science
et bien tu peux demeurer le second
poteau immédiatement multinationale de
2000 salariés la fp l'héritière de
l'agent savas fondée en 1835 mais depuis
les pigeons voyageurs et les premières
liaisons télégraphique les techniques de
transmission bien évoluer à côté du
télex classique que l'on voit ici
l'ensemble de la rédaction a été
entièrement informatisé depuis dix ans
le travail des desk chargé de relire la
copie des bureaux de production est
désormais entièrement codifié provenance
destination urgence de l'information à
traiter un gain de temps considérable
il faut travailler vite et les façon
fiable
si l'on doit d'être à la fois le 1er mai
restait le dernier c'est à dire qu'on
doit pouvoir écrire dans la dans la
seconde 1 minute de l'événement
l'information mais elle doit rester vrai
une semaine après trois jours après
trois heures après alors de la fir lipp
à téhéran en passant par un poste à
moscou vous avez couvert pas mal
d'événements
quelles ont été vos goûts les plus
marquants mais ali pas été effectivement
marquant parce que c'est une affaire qui
a duré pendant pendant un an et j'ai
pris confiance et conscience à l'ip lait
pouvoir l'agencier espère que cette
époque un rédacteur débutants et une
dépêche de l'agencé france presse donc
partant sur tous les fils des journaux
des télévisions des radios faisait la
une dont c'est un pouvoir extraordinaire
que peu de gens mesurent en fait j'étais
le premier à sortir la mort de sousse
l'ofs qu'à l'époque était le numéro deux
du kremlin eh bien j'ai senti après
cette information avec cinq heures
d'avancé ce qui est
très angoissant sur clément on n'a pas
envie de vivre toujours jean
d'information ce genre de situation
parce que pendant cinq heures vous êtes
le seul à annoncer que le numéro 2 de
l'urss vient nourrir et politique ne
vous êtes pas bien sûr
donc c'est très angoissant et lorsque le
flash tombe sur l'agent stas parce que
jean stade louis lille afp les deux
livres on doit lé donné on la faisait
très content mais le coût de la
formation est de plus en plus élevés
n'ayant pas opté comme sa rivale
anglaise repères pour l'information est
creux des micro-entreprises life et se
retrouve face à un marché hexagonal trop
étroit à l'étranger la concurrence
anglo-saxonne est sévère résultat une
vie assez fication s'imposait cette
diversification qui est engagée depuis
quelques années des gens super bien
alors elle a un effet second c'est que
en élargissant notre marché elle nous
permet de diversifier également north
est d'éviter qu'une source de revenu une
demi trop par rapport aux autres et
notamment les abonnements des services
publics des administrations etc
c'est à dire c'est à la fois une
nécessité et une solution des problèmes
un accord de production télévisée avec
l'agent ce gamin un service photo qui se
lancent à l'assaut du marché
international et enfin une agence sonore
qui fournit des bulletins aux radios
locales grâce aux correspondants de la
maison à paris obligé mais néanmoins
difficile dans une période d'austérité
financière
le pml cfa à la ligue mission au japon
nouvelles batailles rangées entre la
police et les écologistes proximité de
l'aéroport international de narita
depuis plusieurs années les incidents de
ce genre ce fric sont fréquents et se
multiplient les rivera dans ses
aéroports s'oppose à l'extension et
piste
cette fois les accrochages ont été
encore plus violent qu'à l'habitude ils
ont fait une vingtaine de blessés parmi
les forces de l'ordre et 200
manifestants ont fait arrêter
margaret thatcher ne changent pas d'avis
à propos de l'afrique du sud elle reste
hostile à des sanctions économiques cela
dit hier ses partenaires du commonwealth
nous ont convaincus d'appliquer
certaines mesures contre pretoria mais
des mesures assez symbolique qui
ressemble plus à un avertissement qu'à
de véritables sanctions mais mme naha
fille jane d'hermann la grande famille
du commonwealth a préféré se souder
autour de l'ordre le mot de sanctions ne
figure pas dans le texte adopté sur
l'afrique du sud tard dans la nuit
madame thatcher a refusé de remettre en
cause la position britannique de premier
investisseur étranger dans le pays de
l'apartheid
les mesures restrictives seulement pas
de nouveaux prêts à pretoria pas des
missions commerciales pas de matériel
informatique à usage militaire
importations limité de pièces d'or
cette dernière mesure est une toute
petite chose trois fois rien explique
madame thatcher
savez vous quelle est la valeur des
importations des pièces d'or en grande
bretagne un demi million de livres pas
question donc de gagner l'afrique du sud
est considéré ce à quoi nous étions
confrontés un embargo total sur toutes
les importations et les exportations
voyez ce quoi nous sommes arrivés des
signaux psychologique sérieux serre de
la part du covan même mineur ces
concessions madame thatcher les accords
du commonwealth et non pas la communauté
économique européenne
le poids du passé permet encore des
évolutions fr3 un nouveau président
madame langlois glandier nommée il ya
dix jours par la haute autorité prendra
officiellement ses fonctions demain
matin la cérémonie de passation des
pouvoirs a eu lieu tout à l'heure voici
en compagnie
andré hollow elle prend la succession on
a appris à cette occasion que madame
langlois glandier exercerait également
la fonction de directeur général une
fonction occupée jusqu'ici par serge
moati dont le départ a été annoncé la
semaine dernière serge moati qui était
directeur général depuis 82 après avoir
été directeur des programmes est un
réalisateur de 39 ans c'est sous son
impulsion kaefer 3 à créer des émissions
comme la dernière séance disneychannel
et cinéma son visa et puis s'est lui
surtout qu'ils avaient mises en oeuvre
le développement des nouveaux programmes
régionaux de notre chaîne andriolo qui
est encore le président de fr3 pour
quelques heures est avec nous ce soir il
s'entretient maintenant avec christian
dauriac
monsieur le président tout d'abord
bonsoir et merci de passer cette
dernière soirée à fr3 en notre compagnie
effectivement vous venez de passer trois
années dans cette société et c'est
effectivement sous votre mandat que se
sont développés un certain nombre
d'initiatives dont le développement des
programmes régionaux
alors avant de nous quitter j'aimerais
vous poser un certain nombre de
questions et j'aimerais que cette
expérience que vous avez pu accueillir
pendant ces quelques années
et bien vous nous en donniez quelques
sentiments parce que souvent on part en
oubliant de dire ces petites choses par
exemple dans quelques mois si tout se
passe comme prévu un certain nombre de
télévision privée locale ou pas local
d'ailleurs vont émettre et des sociétés
de services publics comme fr3 vont se
trouver en concurrence avec ces sociétés
alors fr3 nous avait présidé aux
destinées pendant trois ans c'est une
société qui est prête à cette
confrontation où une société à laquelle
il manque encore un certain nombre de
choses pour se préparer au choc et en
sortit en bon état fr3 et prête
psychologiquement
certainement la société a des atouts
d'abord d'avoir des très bons
professionnels des gens expérimentés
travailleurs et en second lieu la
société nationale comme je lé vécu à une
se blesse
des faiblesses mais quel service public
est trop lourd trop lent trop de
procédures trop de choses qui quoi qui
retarde qui empêche par exemple à je ne
veux surtout pas jeter la pierre aux
syndicats parce que j'ai travaillé avec
eux et ils m'ont souvent apporté
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de positif
mais je crois qu'ils auraient aussi à se
poser la question de la souplesse face à
la concurrence face aux arrivées dans
vous venez de parler alors ce qui va se
passer également et c'est un petit peu
la logique des choses c'est que cette
chaîne qui était il ya quelques années
une chaîne extrêmement centralisé est en
train de devenir une chaîne de plus en
plus décentralisée
quand on parle de décentralisation et
quand on connaît un petit peu les
habitudes du personnel politique en
france
on s'inquiète un petit peu pour
l'indépendance de l'information est ce
que ces inquiétudes vous voulez partager
ou bien les contacts que vous avez eue
avec la classe politique ces derniers
mois vous permettre de dire que la
décentralisation peut se faire non pas
au détriment de la qualité de
l'information et l'indépendance des
journalistes
il faut toujours avoir en vue la liberté
d'information
c'est à dire un travail de journaliste
qui consiste à avoir les faits dans leur
vérité et rapporter les opinions de leur
sincérité
si la régionalisation avance plus si les
structures régionales c'est pas
impensable puisque le gouvernement de
gauche par une loi les annoncer et si
ceux ci aient repris demain dans les
hypothèses indiqué par le président
chaban delmas avant moi je voudrais en
effet en tout les autres causes que la
liberté et l'objectivité de
l'information soit assurée
alors je crois qu'il faudra imaginer une
formule de garantie des rédactions il ya
25 26 journaux régionaux avec artois on
le sait et il ya soir 3 pour qu'il en
soit ainsi se retrouve effectivement
qu'il n'est pas complètement concerné
par cette affaire de décentralisation
soir 3 n'est pas concernée par stéphane
autorisation mais je dois vous dire que
par dans le ce plaidoyer mais en effet
je n'ai plus que quelques heures de
fonction et donc je suis quand même très
libre pour dire que soir 3 et réputé
maintenant et que j'entends beaucoup de
gens qui me parlent de ce journal comme
un journal sérieux objectifs précis
évitant tous les débordements
ça me fait plaisir puisque j'ai beaucoup
fait je crois avec mon équipe pour qu'il
nous soit ainsi mais c'est peut-être un
hommage par encore posthume mais d'un
homme vivant ti laurent monsieur le
président je vous remercie et soir 3 se
poursuit jean jacques peyraud avec la
bourse de paris où le marché a été très
calme aujourd'hui et le dollar tout
aussi calme et tout près de 8 francs
henri leur est aussi le dollar très
proche de la limite tout symbolique il
est vrai des huîtres en français la
détermination des gendarmes autrement
dit des grandes banques centrales est
suffisamment dissuasives pour contenir
la monnaie américaine
l'humeur était moins bonne aujourd'hui à
la bourse de paris où les valeurs
françaises ont cédé 0 5% environ dans un
marché calme
les prises de bénéfices ont donc pesé
sur le marché quelques jours avant la
liquidation mensuelle à new york
l'euphorie de wall street déjà freiné
vendredi soir est encore retombée
aujourd'hui où le dow jones a perdu un
peu plus de cinq points dans un marché
attendant ce très peu défini le temps
demain toujours ensoleillé et
désespérément sec sur la plus grande
partie du pays il y aura tout de même
beaucoup de brume le matin et quelques
gelées blanches dans le centre et dans
l'est peut être aussi quelques averses
orageuses sur le sud des alpes et sur la
corse
les températures ne varieront guerre de
13 à 17 degrés pour les maximales du
nord au sud du pays
demain un premier rendez vous à 19h avec
richard tripots et je vous retrouverai
pour l'édition de la soirée à 22h20 dans
un instant boîte aux lettres un spécial
san antonio ce soir et avant ça je vous
rappelle les principales nouvelles de la
journée excellente fin de soirée et à
demain jacques chaban delmas à soir 3 je
ne retournerai à matignon plus si j'ai
les mains libres pour déterminer et
conduire la politique de la nation
l' agence france-presse à 150 ans est
l'une des trois plus grandes agences du
monde afrique du sud à la demande du
commonwealth la grande-bretagne adoptent
des mesures timides contres pretoria